-You have so much to talk about,
so much coming out.
The new film called "The Nest,"
which was
a Sundance selection --
it's in select theaters Friday,
on demand
starting November 17th.
What -- Can you set up the film
"The Nest"?
-This is a film
regarding a young couple
who decide to leave the States
and head to London in 1986,
around the time
of the economic boom.
And, really, it's just a study
of how a family are pulling
in different directions,
all trying to keep
the family together,
all trying to make
the family work,
but sort of tempted,
if you like,
by the lure of greed, of money,
and -- and not necessarily
what's best for them.
It's a really subtle, elegant,
beautiful look at family life.
And I had a great time
making it.
Carrie Coon plays my wife,
and as I said,
Sean Durkin directs
really wonderfully.
-This new HBO series,
limited series
called "The Third Day."
-Yes.
-I don't know how to set it up
without spoiling it.
-Okay, so there
are two sections.
The first three
are called "Summer,"
and it's about a man dealing
with terrible loss and grief.
I don't think I'm giving
anything away by telling you
he's lost his son.
And he's trying to sort of heal
and remedy his life.
He gets taken to an island
by a young girl
who is trying to do
a good deed for --
and gets stuck on this island.
Now, it's an island,
a real island
off the coast of Essex
called "Osea,"
which has this
old Roman causeway,
so it only opens, this causeway
at certain times of the day.
And we filmed on this island.
The community on the island
and the culture of the island
has been sort of elaborated,
but it's really a sort of symbol
of him trying to lose the --
him trying escape the isolation
of his own grief,
which is, if you like,
the metaphor for the island
and trying to get off this
and away from this community.
And then the second half,
the other three,
are called "Winter,"
and they're another perspective
of the island in the community
from a woman's point of view,
Naomie Harris.
Now, in the middle
is a live event that links them.
I was originally pitched this
by Felix Barrett,
who is the artistic director
of Punchdrunk,
who have a wonderful production
in New York
and around the world.
They were kind of creators
of immersive theater.
And he had this idea --
-Oh, yeah, what did --
what did they do?
-"Sleep No More."
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, of course.
-That's right.
So he came to me -- he had
this idea that he wanted to do,
like, a film story,
whether it was on TV or film,
and then a live event
that was somehow linked
to blur those lines of like,
"is this real?
Is this not real?
Is what I'm watching
actually happening?"
We're gonna have
a single camera.
We'll be there as actors,
as performers,
and the camera will follow us
and the events
for 12 hours live.
So it'll be a kind of
combination
of a sort of live event,
a live piece of theater,
a film in the --
but a film done in one take,
and at times, you know,
you may be watching people,
like, doing some crazy,
like, pagan dancing.
And there may be scenes.
There will be moments when it's
a series of the cross
because it's sort of
a religious theme going through.
There'll also be stuff
that I actually don't know,
because they're going to be
throwing things at me
left, right, and center
over 12 hours.
-12 hours.
I mean, that is --
I love that you're doing this.
I think it's gonna be fantastic.
-[ Chuckles ]
-That's October 3rd.
-Hopefully, hopefully.
-Oh, yeah, no, I'm going
to catch up on "Summer"
and get ready for October 3rd,
then...
-Please do.
-...then for "Winter."
Yeah, no, I'm --
I'm psyched, buddy.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here the Jude Law
in "The Third Day."
Take a look.
-You -- You talked
of sacrifice here.
-Sacrifice?
Sam, that was 2,000 years ago.
-Look at this place.
Is there anything [bleep]
normal here?
I found dead animals
all over this island.
Who's doing that?
No, there were -- there were
pictures down there
hanging on the wall
of Jack the Ripper's victims.
Is that standard?
Men in masks
have just chased me.
Someone nearly shot me.
-Okay, if this is all true,
then what do we do?
-We get off the island!
We find a phone.
We call the police now.
-Okay, how?
-[ Sighs ]
Can you swim?
-Jude Law, everybody.
Check out "The Third Day"
on HBO and HBO Max
and "The Nest"
in select theaters Friday
and on demand November 17th.
Thank you so much
for being here, Jude.
I really, really appreciate it.
-Honestly,
I will never, ever forget
the fact that
you've come into my house.
I love it.
-Thanks for --
Thanks for having me,
and kiss that baby.
-I will.
-Bye, buddy.
-Thank you, I will.
Over and over. Best wishes.
Bye, everyone.
-Thank you. Bye, bud.